looking at the aftermath of a wildfire
might make you think that no good can
come from it after all it demolishes
homes displaces thousands of people and
animals and incinerates millions of
acres of land but believe it or not
there are more benefits to wildfires
than meets the eye for example some
wildlife don't just survive the flames
they actually thrive in the fires wake
[Music]
in 2001 wildfires in New Mexico
destroyed the endangered him as montón
salamanders habitat but the population
survived by hiding out in nooks and
crannies of rocks turns out many
amphibians and smaller animals who can't
outrun the flames take cover in logs
under rocks or by burying themselves in
the dirt at the other end of the
spectrum large animals like elk and deer
flee to streams or lakes for protection
other animals aren't so lucky koalas for
example will instinctively crawl up
trees trapping themselves in the flames
but wildfires aren't just a threat
they're also an opportunity especially
for predators like bears raccoons and
Raptors who hunt down creatures trying
to escape in fact it's even been
reported that Raptors will intentionally
spread fires to flush out prey however
the real benefits of fires come after
the flames die down
pine trees for example open up their
waxy cones and release their seeds
during the fire but it's the ashes the
fire leaves behind that fertilize the
soil so the seeds can grow more over the
fire removes debris as well as dead and
diseased plants which exposes the ground
to more sunlight in the process
this helps seedlings sprout and can
sometimes even spawn thousands of
flowers in the fires wake and many
animals also take advantage of a freshly
burned forest the charred remains of
trees provide the perfect habitat for
insects and small wildlife wood wasps
for instance depend on the burned trees
to lay their eggs and other animals like
black-backed woodpeckers will actively
seek out burned forests for a tasty
snack they binge on bark beetles that
live in the dead trees and make their
homes in the blackened bark and while
this delicate balance between
destruction and new growth has been a
way of life for millennia human
interference is
changing that over the last century we
stifled wildfires so forests became
unnaturally overgrown and contained
plenty of dead wood just waiting to
ignite like a ticking time bomb this
along with increased temperatures and
more droughts has made wildfires more
devastating and frequent than ever
before in places like California making
it harder for plants and animals to
rebound like they used to so if we don't
start clearing dead vegetation and
helping fires run their natural course
we may end up threatening forests and
wildlife more than any fire ever could